- [Interviewer] All right, Julian.
- Hey.
- [Interviewer] Julian, welcome back.
So, you were actually here how long ago?
- I think it was like
four or five months ago.
I was kind of over the summer.
Maybe towards end.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it
feels like it was longer but,
I didn't recognize you when you showed up.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You look so different.
- Yeah, think only kind of worse.
I've lost probably more than a 100 pounds.
- [Interviewer] You've lost a 100 pounds?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
And you're using crystal meth?
- Some Crystal Meth, Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's been
going on since I saw you last.
- You know, I talked about how
I've never been in an
abusive relationship.
I found myself back with an accent.
I never thought would have a hand on me,
and he'd beat the living
dog shit out of me
a couple of times,
we went our separate
ways due to the breakup,
I went harder into my addiction,
not caring about myself
just wanting to numb my pain,
not wanting to feel anything,
but just wanting that high that fix,
that Sunday would just take
me out of myself, you know?
And that's what I've done since then.
It's, you know, I went
harder into my hustle
like, you know, it almost I feels like
I've slept with almost every
single person in long beach
or down here in LA.
I feel like everywhere I turn,
I'm running into the same motherfucker
that I've had run in
with, that I slept with.
And it's like I'm
repeating the same day over
and over and over with this,
with the same people,
but different stories.
It's almost like sometimes
I think I'm getting punked,
like I'm living some kind of alternate.
Like, it doesn't make sense to me.
Like, it makes me crazy to see-
I see the same people
over and over and over.
And then they tell me they know me.
And the next time I see them,
they're driving a cop car
and I don't understand it.
Like I try to figure out like, why?
why is this happening?
Like, why is, you know?
But like people say you're
just being paranoid.
I know it's just not me being paranoid
regardless of what city
I go to, I come down,
I'm trying to sit down here more
'Cause my workers trying
to get me healthy.
So even if I shoot down to long beach
or I shoot down to Wilmington,
or if I shoot down to as
far as San Bernardino,
the same people know
where I'm at, regardless,
no matter where I go the same
peaople are always there.
So not only am I dealing with
my using and my addiction,
I'm dealing with people
that won't leave me alone,
and I keep it to myself or
I'll share with people I trust.
They try to tell me it's all in my mind,
and I don't feel like it's all in my mind.
- [Interviewer] And where,
where are you staying now?
- Right now-
- [Interviewer] Where do you sleep?
Unless don't really sleep much?
- Well, probably the
first time in like months
I probably got over 24 hours of sleep.
I just slept and I slept and
I slept and that's the one.
Yeah. He let me just sleep.
We both slept on that,
all we did was just sleep and rest.
And like today, that's
all I've been trying to do
is just trying to hope to meet someone,
that I could just rest and
like be on the streets.
I get tired of it makes me crazy.
- [Interviewer] How many days
have you been up in a row?
- I don't know.
I mean, all I'll nap on
the bus nap on the train.
I kind of, I don't really keep track.
It's kind of hard to keep
track all I think about
now like today has been,
stay hydrated, stay hydrated.
I haven't even really got high.
I getting high is like
the last thing in my mind.
And everyone just sees me
as some dope being bitch,
and like I'm a money hungry, how?
But at this point, I'm about my survival.
I'm about trying to find
almost like a way out,
but it's like, I know the way out,
but it's like I'm trying to prove a point.
It's like I'm trying to prove something.
And I don't know what that
it's almost like everyone
expects me to quit
and everyone expects me that
she's just a dumb bitch,
to see how much we could just pull her.
- [Interviewer] Are you in
contact with your family?
- My mom tells me when I call her,
how much my oldest Essy is
hurting, how sad she is.
When I do talk to my oldest,
she tells me she's afraid I'm gonna drive,
would die of a drug overdose.
And when I do speak to her,
I tell her I'm not worried
about that.
I'm more worried, I'm gonna
die over the lifestyle,
the lifestyle will kill me
before the drugs ever do.
- [Interviewer] You say the lifestyle,
You mean just the people that pick you up?
- Confusion fucking with all these people
from different areas, crews, cities,
originally they all start talking.
You know what I mean?
it's not very smart on my part
'cause I piss off the wrong
person, not meaning to,
you know, where they feel like I'm just
or they feel like I fucked
them over or took advantage.
We're really, these guys
are doing the same thing,
but it's almost like it's okay.
But if a bitch does it, it's not okay.
- What just keeps you
from, from just quitting
and walking away in your live together?
- Sometimes I don't know for
me if there is a way out,
'cause I'll go to a
program, I'll go to detox,
I'll clean myself up,
I'll do all the right things
for a couple of months
or almost a year, and
I'll go right back to it.
And I'm convinced I will
go right back to it again.
- [Interviewer] So to do a rehab
just seems like a waste of time.
- I think it's fear that
I'm not gonna say it's fear
that I'm just gonna go
back and fuck up again.
That's my fear is I'm gonna
go back again and do it again.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
drives you to go back and relapse?
- When I start feening,
when I start crying,
'cause I are very emotional and very
so involved in my feelings that
when I'm feeling something so deeply,
it could be something so
small as a girl saying,
no, I can't tell you this
dollar soda at McDonald's,
for a dollar a night because
you don't have nine cents.
I will cry over that.
I'll get really angry.
'Cause I feel like if
it was me and someone
needed something to drink,
how can you turn away
someone who needs a drink?
I don't understand what that
could just like, I don't know.
Like I've experienced
things that brings me back
to my toto to being bullied
and being made fun of,
it kills me.
It like kills me, like
the way people treat me
in the way that I allow it.
I know there's a way out, but
I'm still putting it out here.
It's like, I hate myself for it.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Shame makes you-
- Stay out here.
- Stay out here and staying
out here gives you more shame
and it's in the cycle.
- No, I've met good people
on the way and I feel like,
everyone I've come across,
whether big or small, insignificant
or make a significant impact in my life,
I always take those relationships
with me no matter what
because each person teaches me something.
It's made me take a look at myself.
You know?
Like I haven't always been like,
the greatest person
I've been mean and like,
but I know that's not really me,
me treating people like shit
and it's almost like it becomes
like second nature being
on the streets after a while.
It's like you lose who you
are the person, you know?
I feel like I'm spiritually and
emotionally, you get insane.
I don't even know who I am anymore.
- [Interviewer] The street
life and the the drugs
just change your personality. Right?
- You don't know who to trust,
you seeing the person you're talking to
that you could fight in, your friend,
but really nobody out here is your friend.
No one out here care.
- [Interviewer] You feel
like you have any friends?
- Yeah, my friends in recovery,
the people that have been
behind me for many, many,
many years that are waiting
for me to just get it
to fucking come back to
the rooms and surrender.
But it's like, I'm so pride
I have so much pride and ego
that it's like, I won't let me
- [Interviewer] Do you still have hope
of getting your life together?
- I know I'm at the tail end of my using.
I feel like I'm at tail end, but what iS
(indistinct car horns)
what is gonna be it something horrific.
I've always said like,
am I going to have to go
through something so horrific.
that I had I'm forced into being clean?
Or am I gonna make that
decision to walk away?
'Cause even if I walk away,
what has he seen People follow
me no matter where I go,
even clean.
What if I can never get
away from these same men?
This one city that keeps
following me, his family,
I don't understand the
correlation with all of it.
It's the same people.
Is the same certain
individuals that will not
leave me the fuck alone.
I try to figure it out
and it just makes me sick
and it makes me more mad.
And my baby daddy will lose it around.
I asked him for shoes
cause I had no shoes,
he says, I'm afraid to
come around you know.
He knew I was around because
people have been telling him.
So whoever's in his areas warning him
that I've been in the area,
(somber music)
you know, I dunno.
It's just a lie.
It feels complicated
and I don't know sorry.
- [Interviewer] How are you
supporting yourself now?
- I'm not hustling like I was before,
I mean, before I was making,
I wouldn't call it decent money,
but enough to support my hubby, a room,
get food, maybe an outfit now,
today have this guy offered me $5,
and I walked out of his car and said,
you got me fucked up, I'm
not doing nothing for $5.
Yeah, like I'm not how I used to look,
I'm not as pretty as I used to be,
but I still have enough value in me
know that I'm worth more than $5.
You know?
I know I have worth,
I know that there's so much more to me
than what I give myself credit for.
I just don't know how to get back to that,
how I was before
- [Interviewer] It's going
back to your family and option?
- No, if I was to move back at home,
that would never be an
option because me and my mom,
my mom is a very strong Filipino woman.
He believes what she believes
and I don't like to listen,
I like to do what Jullian likes to do,
and I don't follow my mom's rules
because I choose not to follow my rules,
I can't live there,
and I always relapsed.
I always use when I live in her house,
regardless of how good I have it
I can have everything's
working out like life's good,
My friends are back in my life,
everything's back,
I was so find a way to
self sabotage my life.
I go back to a life that I'm not meant for
that I can't handle
because it drugs handle me.
- [Interviewer] What do you feel
like was the biggest mistake
that you've made in your life?
- My biggest mistake,
I would say never.
I would say my biggest mistake
was leaving my ex-husband
and abandoning my daughters.
My life dramatically changed
the moment I walked out on my kids.
I had a good like my ex husband worked,
he didn't want me to work,
he wanted me to be home with my children,
take care of the house,
to care of the children,
make sure the kids get off to school,
the house is immaculate, you know,
let him do his thing, and
I did all those things
and I walked away from him,
'cause so didn't make me happy.
And I'm not one of those females
that chooses to stay in a relationship,
just because there are kids involved.
Yeah that's the right thing to do maybe,
but I don't believe in
giving up my happiness
just because there's children involved.
And I see so many people do that.
They give up a chance at true happiness,
a true chance at love because
he got someone pregnant,
because they wanna do the right thing.
That's just it.
But that was probably my biggest mistake
was leaving my daughters.
'Cause now my oldest is,
she's diagnosed with clinical depression.
She has suicidal ideation.
She blames herself for me leaving.
She believes she's a bad daughter.
And I explained to her that
mommy sick, mommy needs help.
Bad things have happened to
mommy to where she believes
that because she was
abused at that certain age,
my daughters are getting abused too.
No matter how many people
could tell me you're wrong,
you're wrong, you're wrong,
because psychologically
or I've been through
I believe it's gonna
happen to my children.
- [Interviewer] And it continues
on through other generation.
- Yeah.
But I know it because
of what happened to me
doesn't automatically mean
it's gonna happen to my daughters,
or my daughters are not
gonna go down the path
that I've gone or, you know,
youth rose just because I don't know,
not old habits don't always repeat.
- [Interviewer] Somebody
gonna break the cycle.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Julian, thank
you for talking with me.
Can we back again?
I hope you figure something
out and turn your life around
'Cause this is, you know,
it's a dead end, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] See you then.
Alright, thank you.
- Thank you.